this week on quadriga Edda ones election
victory mandate for an autocrat it
wasn't what pollsters predicted a clear
victory for Turkey's president wretch
FTA Padawan who's AKP party won an
absolute majority in parliament the
question is will the president now
tighten his control over Turkish
politics even further the election was
marred by violence and intimidation for
months now the government has been
cracking down on opposition activists
and journalists the peace process with
the Kurds has been shattered divisions
have deepened in the wake of deadly bomb
blasts has a Diwan profited from chaos
he deliberately created as critics say
do Turks really want an autocrat at the
helm quadriga
the international debate your host
Melinda crane
hello and welcome what accounts for an
election result that surprised even the
Act party zone pollsters and what's next
in Turkey that's what we want to talk
about today with three people who
following the situation very closely
there it's a pleasure to welcome Judy
Dempsey she's a longtime columnist for
the International Herald Tribune now a
senior researcher at Carnegie Europe and
the editor in chief of strategic Europe
and she says it's a mandate that could
move turkey away from Europe or toward
Europe it's one or the other and it's a
pleasure to welcome Dilek Corbin she was
born and raised in Turkey she is now a
senior research fellow at the Hattie
school of governance here in Berlin
she's published on the Kurdish question
human rights and media freedom in Turkey
she says Turkish society missed an
opportunity for democracy in the rule of
law with yet another AK Party
single-party rule and finally we're very
pleased to have back on the show Alan
Posner he's a political author at the
German daily diva and he says a Dewan
has no mandate to change the
constitution but he is the legitimate
leader of the strongest Islamic country
in the region and therefore he is our
most important partner so warm welcome
to all of you do like qurban it's just
five months since the AK Party lost its
up
majority in parliament what accounts for
this extraordinary comeback multiple
multiple factors one is the inability of
all political parties after the
elections to form a coalition government
for various reasons which arouse a fear
in the general population that this
might lead to similar results in snap
elections could lead to a similar
outcome which means political
instability which would lead to economic
instability and also during the five
months there's been an increasing
violence and war basically in the
Kurdish region that also sort of scared
people that in the absence of a strong
government things could rapidly
deteriorate which would have
implications for people's you know life
so I would say the biggest factor was
fear fear of instability and fear of
rapid decline in in the economy you know
rising inflation etc so in the end
people like in many countries perhaps
thought of their own personal interests
and went for a more predictable future
rather than take taking the risk of you
know voting for someone else but Judy
Dempsey isn't mr. Aird Owen stoking the
very violence and fear that drove voters
into the arms of his party absolutely
and I just pick you up on what Dilek was
saying predictable future is it that
predictable the occupations party one
through actually censoring the media
harrassing journalists fomenting
violence and actually creating an
atmosphere of instability where now he
says I'm the one that cannot crack that
can create stability and this is a very
M it's a victory that that doesn't
actually guarantee stability and
remember what the stability mean I want
to come right back to stability but Alan
Posner Judy Dempsey has just said the
the election absolutely was not fair but
election observers who were there on
voting day did not report many
observable irregularity
now I think the OECD said it was free a
free election but not a fair election so
Judy is is quite right there there was a
measure of of you know of where people
being really terrorized I mean a TV
station shut down while it was on the
air and stuff like that so it was a free
election it wasn't fair and and I agree
also that it doesn't bode well for
stability because we know that autocrats
are never stable so there's a problem
here
no no question do that current what is
the situation of the media in your
country tell us a bit about the picture
there well I mean there's um there's a
media in Turkey has structural problems
which predate this government which have
deteriorated rapidly in a few past few
years the main issue is of course that
there are conglomerates their holdings
that own media companies you know
belonging you know owned by people
individuals of various political
leanings or economic interest and this
makes them susceptible to government
future because these are companies that
have vested interest in working with the
government so the media has never really
been independent or you know impartial
but things are getting worse because now
the government has been very actively
attacking the media in very novel ways
some of which include that in the past
five years or so very sort of putting
next Puttanesca tactics such as using
critten the tax law or social security
like cetera but very simply going even
beyond that and completely in an
unlawful manner taking over media
companies etc and I should also just
point out to avoid the misunderstanding
it is not my perception that an AKP
single-party rule will bring stability
it's just analyzing why people voted for
that I think for many people that's what
they believed in that a single party
would suggest stability Alan Posner
things for a while we're actually
looking pretty problematic for mister
Arowana if we think back to the
revelations about his family being
implicated
corruption scandals the Ghazi Park
protests the weakening economy what
happened difficult to say really I mean
I wouldn't have put my money on add one
half six months ago but there you have
it he managed to survive all that that's
quite incredible it's a political feat
and if we did it of course in part by
semi legal means by transferring you
know prosecutors who were on the case
against his family to somewhere else by
intimidating journalists who are
investigating his family and as far as
the Kaiser Park was concerned by simple
well police brutality quite frankly so
but you know in in a more democratic
society than Turkey unfortunately is he
wouldn't have survived he did have to go
hand it to him
it can I pick up in this song and if I
may I mean remember the minor the big
mining accident do they I find it
turkeys very very interesting we have
time and again the opposition unprepared
are not able to come together and I know
it's it's very different opposition
outlooks and ideologies in Turkey but
you see this in in these societies
trying to build strong and vibrant and
transparent democracies and when the
opposition comes together they tend to
bicker as they're divided by the the
ruling party and this is a big this is
this is misfit didn't do that badly but
they didn't perform as they should have
so this is the weakness of the
opposition coming together there's a
curve on one party that profited from
the dissatisfaction last June in the
elections in June was the pro-kurdish
HDP party why was it not able to build
on that that gain that it had just five
months ago well we first let's remember
what this party has gone through in the
past five months I mean one reason why
they OSE and also the Parliamentary
Assembly of the Council of Europe has
concluded that the elections were not
fair was because of the harassment the
violence that HTTP had experienced they
have meant by the government well
harassment by the government but also
yeah
because there his officers were raided
people were arrested a number of elected
mayors have been arrested taking out of
office and of course then there was this
big bomb was planted by is in a rally
which included also HTTP members 102
people died this happened just a few
months weeks before the elections so
this was you know HTTP operated in an
extremely you know sort of difficult
conditions so that's one thing and the
second is of course war started again
between the PKK and the Turkish military
and that sort of made it very difficult
for HTP to offer to be found credible by
some of its electorates who had voted
for it before as a Peace alternative on
the other hand let's not forget that MH
TP still succeeded to pass the threshold
they're still in the Parliament and now
the third because a part in the
parliament so one could say that they're
still you know they're not the big
losers of the after of the elections
interestingly enough if one thinks back
to the origins of the a.k party and of
course of mr. a Darwin he once stood for
reform the party's name itself Law &
Development indicates how strong that
commitment was at least in name the fact
is he wanted at that time a break with
the old system of the deep state and
it's corrupt network of the military and
political elites but what does the AK
Party stand for today let's take a look
at one set of arguments the AKP s
victory at the polls won't lead to a
dictatorship other countries also have
systems with a strong president like the
one Edwin envisions many Turks voted for
his Islamist rooted conservative party
because it claims to stand for security
and stability even in the Kurdish
majority city of de Bahia
Jaypee took seven percent of the balance
investors like stability that's why the
country's stock market and currency made
gains after the election results were
announced civil society could also
profit from an economic upswing with a
stable majority behind him another one
will likely seek to de-escalate the
conflict with Kurdish nationalists and
also keep a low profile in Syria turkish
voters have made it clear that they
aren't interested in any more military
adventures Judy Dempsey proponents of
realpolitik say in such a volatile
region that a trade-off between reform
and security is just good common sense
isn't there something to be said for
that
well many governments many Western
governments and democratic governments
really do put stability before reform
thus essentially paying lip service to
their own values actually why can't you
do both why can't you have real politic
and if I can't you have reform and also
if I can't you have a little mixture of
conditionalities well after all with the
situation of the Turkish economy and
it's very unstable neighbors and what's
happening the Middle East
shouldn't turkey be looking to the
European Union and these very wealthy
countries in the European Union for
investment for confidence for for a kind
of reforms so I think there could be a
trade-off I don't think it's one or the
other it can be a balance
Alan Posner that report predicted that
mr. Edwin would moderate his hardline
once he was back in power and feeling
secure we're not seeing too many signs
about yet are we yeah I don't see where
that confidence comes from you know I
don't want to criticize our own video
clip but you know where do they he says
he's got a mandate for the policy he's
been following up till now it seems to
me so why would he it seems to be a
winning card why would he moderate
himself also it's not only in his own
power I mean let's face it the PKK the
Kurdish terrorist group they attacked
first out of an only struck back let's
face it in Syria ad one doesn't control
events he
reacting to events so whatever he does
it's not only dependent on who on what
he or what he does I mean he is reacting
to events possibly beyond his control
Putin intervention intervening in Syria
goodness knows what the PKK is gonna do
now so I don't see any cause for
optimism not only because because of
what add one might think or do but
because of what other actors are gonna
do do that curve on where do you see
things going from here mr. Allen has
said one thing he is definitely looking
to do is change the constitution to
strengthen the office of the presidency
his supporters say that's essential for
economic growth just respond very
quickly just to note certainly the PKK
was to attack first but this came after
our don personally announced that the
peace process was over if the you know
the peace process that he had himself
started this was before the June
elections he really used he really was
very manipulative in the way in which he
provoked you know sort of Kurdish strong
Kurdish reaction not just when a PKK but
also from http why to appeal to national
sports and it worked a considerable
amount of the nine percent increase of
in DHAP votes comes from the MH P which
is the Turkish nationalist party that is
an old tactic by the way that aired on
had timing and resorted for example in
the 2004 local elections this is not
something new he does it all the time as
for Syria certainly he didn't start the
war in Syria but he and his government
AKP government they were very clearly
backing various opposition forces
including fundamentalist Islamists some
of which ended up in is etc and let's
not forget that this bombing that I
mentioned earlier in Ankara the names of
those the individuals who planted the
bomb their names were known to the
general public months before the police
were apparently after them and so to
this government the problem is that this
government doesn't see is as nearly a
threat as the PKK and this is their
official policy
coming back to your question he they do
have the power to change the
constitution but it's they still need to
submit it to the referendum I don't
think that in a referendum they would
have a yes vote to change the regime to
a presidential system because that was
one of the that was the issue in the
June elections having said that they
don't need it anymore
Iran also declared this in records that
there is a de facto presidential system
in Turkey and we see the signs of that
we will see more signs of that Judy
Dempsey as I say the the supporters of
are the ones say executive presidency
lots of countries have it it's not the
equivalent of a dictatorship you're
shaking your head violently there but
but these are the arguments that are
being made and in fact there are
countries with strong presidencies that
are by no means dictators yes and let us
give the examples of those countries
with strong presidencies and not in
particularly if shiny democracies and
you see any any economic reform with
such a strong president with such strong
execut executive powers the idea there's
a strong president can introduce
economic reforms is a contradiction in
terms
economic reforms demand fresh air
liberalisation transparency openness
clear property rights investor friendly
given the situation in Turkey I cannot
see President Erdogan guarantee this
however however if there's any silver
lining in this and I hope there is for
the Turks and for the Turkish people
this is this that the the worse the
economy comes it becomes Iran must he
has no option but to look to genuine
reforms otherwise they'll be no foreign
direct investment which actually fed the
Turkish economy this is about investor
confidence as well Alan Posner you said
in your opening statement that you
believe everyone has no mandate to
change the Constitution but that we have
to rely on him he's our most important
partner so hold our noses and just do
the dirty deal yeah definitely I mean
the hold our noses I mean let's face it
I don't want it's not Putin other one
it's not Assad God one is not even our
CC energy in Egypt and one is someone
who is elected
in a free not fair election and he has
the confidence of the Turk of the
majority of the Turkish people and is
vitally important to solve the problem
in Syria
he's vitally important for solving the
refugee crisis or helping solve the
refugee crisis there's no alternative to
doing business with him and we shouldn't
be too cagey about it let's go for it
with condition we can put conditionality
no problem with that but let's face it
he's in the stronger position now than
he was a month ago and a year ago and
two years ago let's face up to that
reality let us take a brief look at what
it is that the EU is expecting for mr.
Atta one it recently offered Turkey
three a billion euros in financial aid
to keep some 2.2 million Syrian refugees
on its own so let's take a look before
the vote it was clear that the European
Union would prefer a strong AKP showing
everyone stands for stability and is a
key player in the ongoing migrant crisis
German Chancellor Angela Merkel's visit
to Turkey shortly before the elections
enhanced the ruling party's status
indirectly providing its campaign with
support
this despite the fact that regime
critics and minorities in Turkey are
still persecuted and arrested and eat
you progress report rebukes heroines
government for that and other rights
abuses but it was only made public after
the vote
critics say in order not to hurt AKP
chances at the polls and suddenly talks
on Turkish accession to the EU are back
on the table
although Merkel's Christian Democrats
have always been against the idea but
Turkey no longer has to play the role of
supplicant in talks it can now also
dictate conditions
the equipment did Chancellor Merkel in
effect help mr. Edwin with his campaign
and possibly even with his victory by
visiting him in Turkey two weeks before
the election well absolutely I mean of
course we don't know any we don't have
an empirical data to able to measure the
concrete impact on the votes probably it
was not that significant but in terms of
giving legitimacy to aired on absolutely
and it's incredible that Merkel went
against her own principles and
well-established rules in Europe and the
u.s. that you just don't go and visit a
head of a state right before the
elections but you heard what Alan Posner
just said we have to rely on mr.
elderman we have to rely on Turkey it
may not be appealing it may contravene
some of our values but it's all we have
well I don't agree it's just amazing
what happened to European values on the
certainly turkey mr. I mean certainly
they have to work with the Turkish
government obviously but to see that we
that that that are done is as he is with
his policies with this you know sort of
undemocratic Democratic stance is the
option is really insane I think the
Europeans and the German government are
so panic with having refugees here in in
Europe that they just want to basically
send them back or keep them in Turkey at
all costs give the money and you know
sort of violate their own obligations
under the Geneva Conventions for refugee
protection forget about the principles
democratic principles that the EU
supposedly stands for
forget about the Copenhagen political
criteria and just you know sort of make
everyone believe that this is the only
option
Judy Dempsey your own opening statement
said that the election result would move
turkey either away from Europe or closer
to it clearly from the discussion we've
had here so far most of you agree that
probably this election result will move
Turkey further away yet it sounds from
that report like the e is ready to
embrace mr. out Erwin no matter how far
away he forces the EU and does 28 member
states there and and the biggest
obstacle that actually stopped the EU
coming closer to Turkey and opening up
these negotiations chapter
Cypress don't forget what what how
important Cyprus is if Iran had the
political antenna and I think he has
maybe for this he could actually make a
deal over the divided island of Cyprus
this divided is been going on far too
long and the Turks invaded northern part
in 1974 here's a chance actually for
Iran for statesmanship and if the Cyprus
issue is resolved
Cyprus as an EU member can't continue to
actually prevent the EU from opening
these negotiations with Turkey is we're
not talking about the EU were talking
about this film countries that do not
want a turkey to be close to be you
Chancellor Merkel plays a pivotal role
in all of this Alan Posner does the EU
really have no leverage to push Turkey
in regard to the treatment of the media
of the Kurds does the EU really need
Turkey more than turkey needs the EU yes
you need circa more than turkey needs EU
we we had the chance a couple of years
ago we miss it because we're obsessed
with with the Greek crisis and instead
of using the Greek crisis to force the
Greeks to cooperate sort of using the
Cyprus crisis they had any coming crisis
to cooperate with the Turks we let it
all roll and now we're reaping the
results of markets shortsightedness
in in this in this respect we don't have
much leverage if you know it's not a
one-way street
don't Turkey and the Turkish civil
society it's a turkish opposition but
the turkey meets europe as well so look
what's happening in azerbaijan relations
have completely sound look at the region
the turkey finds itself in where is the
region of stability this is europe
frankly turkish business the turkish
diaspora in europe they they need each
other it's not it and it's a reciprocal
relationship that could be exploited by
both sides do the quran very briefly
back to this deal that the EU has been
making with turkey if it in fact
subcontracts the task of holding back
migrants keeping them on turkish so what
kind of treatment can the migrants
expect in turkey well
first of all let's not forget that they
don't have refugee status Turkey has a
reservation geographical reservation to
the Geneva Convention it just doesn't
accept anybody who comes from east of
Turkey as refugees these people at best
have guest status they cannot work they
don't they have they cannot access
education what if what awaits them is
what they've been living for four years
discrimination extreme poverty begging
on the streets and you know with no
prospect of future I hope that at least
you know the EU and you know angle
America would be I'm gonna say humane
enough to at least impose on Turkey to
change these refugee policies and offer
our future for these people and and not
make the mistake of declaring Turkey a
safe space we're just a week ago two
syrian activists were beheaded by is in
alpha in Turkey Alan Posner is telling
us the EU doesn't have leverage it's not
gonna be able to drive that kind of a
bargain would you agree also to lead us
otherwise why was Eric lund cares so
much to pose with America he does care
about his prestige after all Judy
Dempsey our title mandate for an
autocrat was that what that election was
no it was a mandate for risk and airdyne
has to choose which side is going to
jump okay thank you very much to all of
you of you for being with us today and
thanks to all of you out there for
tuning in see you soon